>> Sean: MORE DISTURBING
EVIDENCE OF THE LAWLESSNESS
TAKING OVER AMERICA'S DEMOCRATI
RUN CITIES LOCATE YOUR SCREEN
OUT IN LOS ANGELES, THEFTS
AGAINST CARGO TRAINS ARE NOW
SPIKING AND THE UNION PACIFIC
RAILROAD IS NOW LASTING FAILED
FAR LEFT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
GEORGE GASCON FOR LENIENT
SENTENCES THAT DOWNGRADE SERIOU
THEFT CHARGES TO A LESSER
OFFENSE.
ACCORDING TO UNION PACIFIC,
TRAIN CONTAINER THEFT INCREASED
BY A WHOPPING 160 PERCENT JUST
FROM 2020 AND 2021 IN LA COUNTY
CAMA AND OF COURSE IT'S NOT ONL
PROPERTY, THE FAILURE TO ADDRES
GROWING CRIME IS COSTING LIVES
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
TONIGHT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
FOLLOW THE MURDER OF GRAD
STUDENT UCLA GRADUATE STUDENT
WHO WAS FATALLY STABBED OVER TH
WEEKEND WHILE WORKING AT AN LA
FURNITURE STORE.
AT THE LAPD IS NOW OFFERING A
$250,000 REWARD FOR INFORMATION
THAT LEADS TO THE CAPTURE OF
THIS SUSPECT NOW IDENTIFIED AS
31 -YEAR-OLD SMITH.
HOW MANY MORE OF THESE STORIES
DO WE HAVE TO COVER BEFORE FAR
LEFT DISTRICT ATTORNEY START
TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY?
IN A DEMOCRATIC RUN CITIES AND
STATES FAILING TO PROTECT PEOPL
IN FAILING TO PROTECT PROPERTY
AND FAILING TO PREVENT
LAWLESSNESS FROM COMPLETELY
TAKING OVER A.
HERE WITH REACTION FOUNDER OF
ORDER FOR AMERICA PAC AND FORME
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE LARRY
ELDER.
LARRY, I LOOK AT THIS YOUNG
WOMAN, SHE'S KILLED, I LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
RAILROADS, CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG BUT WHEN WHEN THEY
DEFUNDED THE LAPD AND CUT ITS
BUDGET, WASN'T IT VICE PRESIDEN
KAMALA HARRIS THAT PRAISE THE
LAPD?
>> THAT'S RIGHT SHE SAID WE NEE
TO REIMAGINE THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND THEY DIVERTED A
LOT OF FUNDS FOR SO-CALLED YOUT
PROGRAMS GREAT SHORTLY AFTER
GAVIN NEWSOM SURVIVED THE RECAL
HE SIGNED A BUNCH OF BILLS 12
CRIME ENHANCEMENT HE FELT A
LARGE NUMBER OF THESE BUT BAD
GUYS WE'RE BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE AND THEREFORE THEY ARE
VICTIMS OF SYSTEMIC RACISM
BECAUSE YOU MANY OF THEM ARE
BLACK AND BROWN.
THEY CAN BE TRACED BACK TO OUR
SOFT ON CRIME DA THAT GAVIN
NEWSOM SUPPORTED AND THAT GEORG
SOROS SUPPORTED AND GUESS WHO
ALL SUPPORTED IT, MAXINE WATERS.
SHE LIVES IN HANCOCK PARK, THIS
IS THE UPSCALE AREA WHERE THIS
YOUNG LADY WAS WORKING AT A
FURNITURE STORE.
THE VERY POLICY AND PEOPLE THAT
MAXINE WATERS SUPPORTED, OUR
COMING VERY CLOSE TO HOME, SO
MAYBE NOW THEY WILL RECONSIDER
SOME OTHER POLICIES THAT HAVE
IMPERILED THE LIVES OF CITIZENS
IN LA COUNTY IN IN LOS ANGELES.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
IT IS GETTING WORSE.
IC THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON THE FUND
DISMANTLE THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON
NOBEL LAWS, THEY DOUBLE DOWN ON
CHARGING SERIES WITH PEOPLE WIT
SERIOUS CRIMES AND REDUCING THE
CHARGES TO MISDEMEANORS.
THAT IS COMMON PRETTY MUCH IN
EVERY BLUE CITY AND EVERY
DEMOCRATIC RUN STATE AND THE
COUNTRY.
>> A GROWING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ARE BEING RECONSIDERING THINGS
LIKE PROPOSITION 37 THAT ALLOWS
YOU TO STEAL UP TO $950 A DAY,
BUT PER STORE, IF YOU GET CAUGH
THE FIRST AND THAT HAPPENS IS
THAT THEY WRITE YOU A TICKET AS
A MISDEMEANOR.
THEN WE HAVE PROPOSITION 57 THA
REDUCES A WHOLE BUNCH OF
CATEGORIES OF CRIME TO
NONVIOLENT CRIMES THEY INCLUDE
ASSAULT ON A POLICE OFFICER,
THAT'S NOW A NONVIOLENT CRIME,
SERIAL ARSON IS A NONVIOLENT
CRIME, FELONY DOMESTIC BATTERY
IS NOW A NONVIOLENT CRIME.
A GROWING NUMBER OF PEOPLE ARE
BEGINNING TO RECONSIDER THESE
POLICIES BECAUSE NOW IT'S COMIN
CLOSE TO HOME.
WHEN I RAN FOR GOVERNOR, A LOT
OF PEOPLE SAID WHEN IS
CALIFORNIA GOING TO HIT ROCK
BOTTOM.
I SAID WHEN THE CRIME COMES TO
PLACES LIKE BRENTWOOD AND MALIBU
, AND NOW THE CRIME HAS
COME TO THOSE AREAS.
>> Sean: NOW GAVIN IS TALKING
ABOUT A SINGLE-PAYER HEALTH
SYSTEM YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
THEY HAD A SHOT, IT COULD'VE
BEEN A GREAT GOVE